[Music]
when so-called islamic state wanted to
kill kocha and her husband mahmoud
they fled with their children to mount
sinjar the mountain in northern iraq is
regarded as sacred by the yazidis
mount sinjar saved a lot of yazidis when
no one else was helping us
her husband made it to the mountain but
kocha and the children were abducted by
is
they were enslaved raped and sold time
and again
like animals
[Music]
after two years kocha and her five
youngest children were finally released
but one older daughter and two older
sons are still missing
in the mornings after they get up basima
jihan
and hanan like to play in their homemade
[Music]
kitchen
they didn't give us anything to eat they
were evil
they kept on helping themselves to the
girls
in the tent katja prepares bread dough
she doesn't want to leave the mountain
it's the only place in iraq she feels
safe
she is still traumatized by her
experiences
as well as by the thought that three of
her children are still prisoners of is
kocha only knows that her
fifteen-year-old daughter arvine was
forced to marry an is fighter
she has no idea what's happened to her
two older sons
i can't think of anything else i'll be
working on something
then leave it for a moment and i'll
forget all about it
it's awful sometimes i'll be cooking
something on the stove
and let it burn i'm just not normal in
the head anymore
i went to the doctor but they said it
didn't matter what medicine i took
it wouldn't help because i just think
too much
kocha wants to stay strong for her
children's sake
working helps her get through the day
the family was given 20 sheep by an aid
organization
they used the used milk to make yogurt
the money they earn from selling it is
their only source of income
the animals mean a lot to us they keep
us busy and distract us
her husband mahmoud drives the flock up
the mountain to graze
during qatar's imprisonment mahmud
helped to defend mount sinjar against is
forces
back then he didn't know if his family
was alive or dead
the couple rarely talk about what they
experienced they're too preoccupied with
trying to discover the fate of their
three missing children
we ask around everywhere we even ask aid
workers
and people smugglers who free abducted
people whether they can help us
believe me whenever someone's freed i go
there the same day
or the next morning at the latest and i
ask
but so far his efforts have been in vain
over 2 000 yazidi families live on mount
sinjar
and almost all have family members
missing
a few months ago a child care facility
was set up at this camp
it's open for two hours a day
today eight-year-old hannah reads out
what's written on the board
[Music]
but most of all the social workers want
the children to have fun
[Applause]
we don't discuss
sometimes kocha has no idea how to ease
her children's pain
they all suffer from nightmares the is
men kept taking the children
to make kocha obey them
they were held in a cellar without any
light for months on end
in desperation she tattooed their names
on their arms
using a nail and ash for ink
i did it so that they wouldn't forget
their names
when they took the children away from me
is would give them new names
but then the leader said if i see a name
on an arm
i'll cut off that arm so i stopped look
here
i only did half her name
has taken precautions to ensure that his
family will never go through anything
like this again
he's got a kalashnikov hidden in the
closet
next time he says he won't be afraid to
use it
i've learned from the past we trusted
our neighbors then
they said they were our friends but they
killed us yazidis
i need a weapon to defend my family
we're afraid
while the family is eating lunch mahmud
is called outside
german aid agency vailtongahefe is
looking for workers at the refugee camp
the men can earn 300 u.s dollars in six
days
but some of the men here aren't on the
list mahmoud included
he's frustrated we've waited a year for
an opportunity like this
we need the money we
goes with the other men to the aid
agency's tent
a sizable crowd has gathered and the
project manager is having a hard time
keeping a handle on the situation
the people up here on the mountain don't
want to work in the villages down below
because they're scared something won't
happen to their families while they're
gone
mahmud is told that he has one of the
jobs it starts tomorrow
but today he's promised kotcha that
they'll go and see their old house
in their car which he managed to salvage
leaving the mountain isn't easy for
kocha
items that the yazidis left behind four
years ago in their panic to flee from is
forces
still litter the roadside kocha's escape
attempt
also ended here the route to their old
village passes through sinjar
once the capital of iraq's yazidi
community
around 70 of its buildings have been
destroyed
what's awful is that they gave six or
seven or eight-year-old girls
to 10 or 12 men and that an is
fighter gets a 10 year old girl pregnant
that's the worst thing
their home village rambussi is deserted
it was one of the first villages taken
by is
their house has been wrecked and looted
everyone's gone
they'd invested all their savings in
this house
mahmoud earned good money working as a
foreman
they say their muslim neighbours helped
is
one of their abducted daughters was
abused for months in the building across
the road
there's no way kocha and mahmud would
live here again
we have nothing in common a lot of
muslims still live in the next village
we yazidis will never be able to live
with muslims again
after what happened
they were all with is or supported them
plus they weren't driven out only god
can avenge us
and then she takes a video on her cell
phone she wants to show the children
their old house
it's very quiet in the car on the return
trip
they pass by thousands of tents the
makeshift homes of other yazidis who are
too afraid to return to their villages
soon as they arrive 10 year old gian
wants to see the pictures
she's homesick is that her cupboard
that was for the tv and where's the
water tank
they took it too that's all that's left
in the evening is outside preparing the
beds for the night
it's too stuffy inside the
her tent has lived on mount sinjar for
two years now
the mountain has been their refuge but
they don't intend to stay here
when god willing our children come back
we'll leave iraq
that would enable them to go to
australia
but leaving now would mean giving up
hope
and it's the hope of seeing their
missing children again
that keeps them on the mountain
you